hier ist bild live und hier wollen wir
streiten hier wollen wir eine live
debatte verfolgen im bundestag
impfpflicht ja oder nein diese debatte
läuft gerade jetzt im bundestag versehen
sie ja eingeblendet wir schauen auch
immer unserem gesundheitsminister in die
augen mit unserer karl lauterbach kann
man schon sagen und wir wollen natürlich
wissen was passiert auf den straßen hier
in berlin wo sich viele hunderte
menschen fest tausende menschen
versammelt haben um gegen die
impfpflicht zu demonstrieren karl
lauterbach ist gerade aufgestanden gehen
wir da gerade verweist wahrscheinlich
weil er claus strunz beim streiten
zuschauern möchte hierbei bild live erst
bei uns im studio unser bild leib chef
mit einer klaren meinung gegen die
allgemeine impfpflicht klaus warum
weil sie nicht verhältnismäßig ist weil
nicht alle maßnahmen ausgeschöpft sind
die man hand ergreifen können weil man
dem virus immer nur hinterher impft ich
war ja überzeugt wenn das anders wäre
weil man nicht wirklich
nicht mehr ansteckend ist uns auch nicht
mehr angesteckt werden kann dass der
große unterschied zu den masern also wer
immer den masern vergleich macht macht
an dieser stelle einen fehler und weil
natürlich auch nicht ausreichend
aufklärung betrieben ist über mögliche
empfohlen das bedeutet die phase der
kommunikation und animation ist noch gar
nicht vorbei ich setze auf animieren
stand auf angst politik und ich finde
jeder der jetzt für die allgemeine
impfpflicht ist setzt diese
unglückselige
politik strategie der angstmacherei fort
denn das eigentliche argument lautet
doch immer wenn wir die impfpflicht
nicht einführen dann müssen ganz ganz
ganz ganz viele sterben aber es müssen
sowieso ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
sterben und deshalb versagt dieses
argument der bayerische
gesundheitsminister klaus holetschek ist
jetzt bei uns zum großen streitgespräch
[Musik]
er hatte tags schön dass sie bei uns
sind wir herzlichen dank für ihre zeit
sie haben eben gerade die argumente von
claus strunz schon hören können was
entgegnen sie dir
ja es geht nicht um angst es geht um
vernunft das ist das thema und wenn sie
jetzt auf das morgige datum schauen dann
sind wir jetzt zwei jahre in dieser
pandemie da ging's los webasto das große
thema und wenn sie jetzt hin was in
diesen zwei jahren passiert ist dann bin
ich der meinung die impfpflicht ist die
ultima ratio ich war früher auch gegen
die impfpflicht stehen wir einen sturz
zu argumente sind besser wir müssen die
menschen überzeugen aber wir sind an
einem punkt wo wir mit argumenten nicht
weiterkommen niedrigschwellige angebote
kooperationen mit verbänden vereinen
dehoga mit allen also es hatte jeder die
chance überall im vorbeigehen eine
impfung zu kriegen informationen
kampagnen jetzt wieder eine kampagne der
bundesregierung
ich weiß gehört wie viel man noch machen
sollen wir erreichen die menschen an
einem punkt nicht und ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt eine exit strategien und
die führt über eine allgemeine
impfpflicht die aus meiner sicht
befristet sein muss aber sie muss kommen
und zwar jetzt
jetzt tauchen wir schon neue begriffe
auf befristet und wird im bundestag auch
diskutiert ein antrag altersgrenze also
alle ab 50 für die soll es dann
verbindlich sein ich glaube dass das
verkleistert worum es eigentlich geht
ich glaube dass der logistikunternehmer
start und sie haben jetzt einige dinge
aufgezeigt da würde ich jetzt kritisch
entgegen halten wenn die alle nicht
funktioniert haben sind sie halt falsch
oder schlecht gemacht worden wenn ich
den bundeskanzler gestern sehe wie er da
dieses plakat hoch hält wo wirklich also
quasi die wahrscheinlich der
schlechteste werbegrafiker auf den
schlechtesten texter getroffen sind die
dann das schlechteste plakat aller
zeiten gemacht haben dass an eine
toiletten werbung auf
autobahnraststätten erinnert aber doch
nicht an die wichtigste impfkampagne
dann trete ich dem argument dass alles
versucht worden ist jedenfalls auf
bundesebene als bayer oder besser gesagt
franke würde ich ja vielleicht noch mit
einigem wohlwollen sagen in bayern haben
sie es vielleicht noch mehr
krachenlassen was die werbung angeht
bundesweit stimmt es jedenfalls nach
meiner auffassung nicht und deshalb
finde ich unangemessen ich finde auch
dass in den persönlichen gesprächen noch
ein schlüssel liegt also es gab eben
eine persönliche ansprache aller
bundesbürger mit den argumenten ich
persönlich zum beispiel bin geimpft und
gemustert und hatte auch gar keine
folgen jedenfalls ist mir noch kein
zweiter kopf gewachsen also es ist
sozusagen nichts eingetreten von dem was
an den an die wand gemalt wird darüber
freue ich mich ich sehe aber auch
menschen mit ihm folgen und ich sehe
auch menschen die angst haben auch im
folgen zu haben und auch da muss man mit
mit argumenten erst rein bevor man mit
der spritze droht und das ist das was
mir als bürger wirklich weh tut dass es
jetzt womöglich im parlament eine
mehrheit dafür gibt dass mit der spritze
drohen das mittel in einer demokratie
sein kann statt die überzeugungskraft
die animation und das wirklich mit
überzeugungen auf menschen zugehen als
mittel der wahl da es sind noch eins
vielleicht weil mich das absatz unseres
des kurses interessiert ich glaube dass
man fünf bis zehn prozent sowieso nie
erreicht sie lassen sich übrigens auch
nicht impfen mitnehmen pflicht also
selbst wenn man sie für verhältnismäßig
hielt es sie bei diesem wunsch alle oder
98 prozent oder 95 prozent zu impfen ein
schon mit ansage für sagen das mittel
ich will gar nicht darüber sprechen dass
wahrscheinlich ewig dauert bis jeder
dann die hand und die ganze logistik
wieder nicht klappt ich glaube die zahl
die wir brauchen müssen wir erstmal
benennen wann ist denn herdenimmunität
80 85 70 prozent und die erreichen wir
auch ohne impfpflicht und den weg müssen
wir gehen statt derartig in ein
freiheitsrecht oder in ein recht
einzugreifen wir müssen sonst ja nur
noch mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen
es geht also um den in den die abwägung
zwischen dem schutz der allgemeinheit
und
einem eingriff in die selbstbestimmung
meinen eigenen körper betreffend und ich
kann nur wirklich nach lage der dinge
keinen trug eine übergroße notwendigkeit
für den schutz der allgemeinheit mehr
erkennen jedenfalls keinen der es
legitimieren würde in die
selbstbestimmung im umgang mit meinem
körper einzugreifen und ich sage es noch
einmal ich habe für mich die
entscheidung getroffen ich las da
eingreifen weil mir einfach bei meiner
persönlichen risiko abwägung dass eine
besser und sinnvoller erscheint als das
andere und die abwehr man muss aber
jeder selber treffen dürfen für sich in
einer freien gesellschaft sorgt jetzt
also ich kann nur noch mal sagen über
kampagnen kann man sicherlich streiten
es liegt an euch hier könnte von der
bild zeitung um eine große kampagne noch
mal machen zum impfen vielleicht mit
neuen ideen ich glaube man kann so was
immer besser machen die franzosen an das
mit mehr empathie gemacht wir haben das
vielleicht manchmal zu wenig mit der
emotion probiert aber wir haben aus
geklärt werden informiert die ärzte ich
kann ihnen sagen es gab so viele
gespräche ist so viele auch wirklich
überzeugende argumente an vielen vielen
stellen wo jeder auch die chance hatte
sich zu informieren wir haben über die
institutionen informierte spy die stiko
vielleicht war es schon mal eine zuviel
eine vielzahl von informationen dass man
schon die richtige nicht mehr gefunden
hat aber ich glaube nach zwei jahren
sind wir wirklich an einem punkt
gekommen wo wir jetzt entscheiden müssen
es geht nicht um die herdenimmunität ist
geht um eine grundimmunisierung wir
jetzt sorge tragen müssen damit wir
rauskommen aus dieser pandemie damit wir
die freiheitsrechte eben nicht mehr
einschränken müssen damit wir nicht mehr
von lockdown zu lockdown hoppeln sondern
damit wir wieder rauskommen aus diesem
thema und das wollen doch die menschen
ist auch das was ihr immer wieder
propagiert zurück zur normalität aber
wir brauchen dazu jetzt noch mal einen
mutigen schritt wir müssen die ethischen
und juristischen fragen natürlich
diskutieren es sind abwägungen
verschiedener grundrechtseingriffe aber
ich glaube die sind verhältnismäßig
schauen sie auf die intensivstationen
was sich dort abgespielt hat bis vor
kurzem wir mussten ab verlegen wir
mussten menschen mit dem kleeblatt
system in andere bundesländer verlegen
weil die intensivstationen voll waren
die pflegekräfte sind am limit unser
gesundheitssystem kollabiert es macht
sich doch keiner leicht diese
entscheidung ist doch keiner aus der
hosentasche die impfpflicht ich selber
habe mir wirklich schwer getan aber ich
bin auch der meinung man muss auch mal
korrigieren können wenn man an einem
punkt ist wo man mit argumenten wo man
mit der kraft der überzeugung eben nicht
mehr weiterkommt dann ist das die ultima
ratio und ein staat muss in der lage
sein auch mal solche dinge umzusetzen
österreich macht es uns vor wir sind
nicht in der lage bürokratismus in der
pandemie dinge die ich nicht mehr
erleben möchte da müssen wir anders
angehen da müssen wir mutiger sein und
wir brauchen die diskussion jetzt wir
brauchen aber eine entscheidung und auch
eine zeitnahe umsetzung lassen sie mich
noch ein wort zur einrichtungs bezogen
im fleet sagen die haben wir jetzt im
moment sie sehen ja wie das auch zu
verwerfen führt deswegen ist es wichtig
dass man auch diesen menschen sagt ihr
seid nicht das opfer der party - kein
sonderopfer tragen sondern die
einrichtungs bezogenen pflicht ist nur
der erste schritt zur allgemeinen wie es
ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
die wir gemeinsam tragen müssen und an
dieser schnittstelle sind wir jetzt und
ich hoffe dass wir zeitnah entscheiden
als minister im streitgespräch mit claus
strunz unserem bild live chef vielen
herzlichen dank für diese
leidenschaftliche debatte